i've taken an assistant governor hostage
in a maximum security so everywhere i go
i've got loads of prison offices around
because they think i'm going to take
another one right and that's six or ten
man unlock ten men unlock there you go
what does that mean that means you're
only only 10 officers in riot gear with
a governor an so and a po can open your
door
[Music]
guys you've obviously been on lava
before but we want to introduce
yourselves who are you and why are you
here today i'm bobby cummings obe
um
and i'm not a gangster i never had been
a gangster i'm a businessman whose
business was crime
and uh that's how i'm sorry it was just
business with me if you look at the
police books it said um he ruled north
london for ten years was thrown off
called kennedy and terrorized north
london for ten years i'm marvin irber
i um
i come from a a mixed
a cultural relationship black no black
dogs no irish in the 70s i got brought
up in a racist environment very
conflictuous um drug dealing um drug
addiction i was addicted to
crack and heroin from the age of 11 12
13 years of age um dealing drugs and
committing crime from
eight nine ten eleven years of age got
all the way up to 17 18 19 started
committing armed robberies
um like all the people like bobby and i
used to look up to as a kid yeah so
i got involved in crime from
school all the way through my
adolescence
what happened was i'm working in
shipping office so i'm a straight game
kid straight family
i'll go through finsbury park and with
some kids on there that was all snug out
of school because they're bad lads fired
a starting pistol so two old bill from
stoke knowing and walked in
and they're having about these kids and
i went oh you can't do that and they
would do i said you can't do that i said
you gotta have a responsible adult with
you before you can talk to young fellas
like that when you simply know a lot
about the law i said i know my rights he
went is that right and he's walked out
at a park they'd come back threw a cup
throat on the on the grass he went we
just see you throw that so they've
nicked me so much that's kind of the law
station
and i said you said what's going on i
said they fitting me up he went well i
said they fitted me up they planted it
even policemen don't do that i went they
did i'm telling you my dad says to me he
said look they said if you go guilty if
you get up the steps you're gonna go
bolster or which i didn't care because a
lot of my pals is in there he said but
if you go guilty there's ten by five
with more cases i'll pay the ten buck
fine i will take it took it biggest
foolish mistake i made in my life but i
took it come out but it's in the
newspaper
get the sack from my job
so i'm sitting there with the boys in
the greek cab and i thought i was
talking about what they was doing
they're doing silly stuff you know
and i thought they ain't organized now
i've always been an organizer i can look
at something and i can plan it i've
always been a planner
and i thought this is a business
basically this is why i always say i was
never a gangster never wanted to be a
gangster i wanted to run a business but
i think there's a thing about little
people we've got big egos and my ego six
foot seven and i thought why you know
i've got to be the best day i can't just
be good at it i want to be better than
all the rest so that when you're going
to come in with us bob i went there all
right but we do it marble i said because
there's not enough cake here for all of
us and it was all little gangs you know
from different manners and like the
archbishopri and all that so we had go
go go war in them days i thought i was
invincible i thought i can do anything i
want and someone sent me you can't do
that i went on bobby cummings someone do
what i like i can shoot her if i want
you know if
i can do anything i want and i really
believe that was invincible until they
backed me up and then
how many years of crime was you got
crime or time in jail no crime in crime
well i was in it from the age of 16
right up until
i've got the oba
basically
so
we're talking about 2011 i've got the ob
on the new years on this list
and i was applying until uh 1966
so look out 45 years old oh
you've done me you've done me i'm 42
years old i'm 42 years old so between us
we got nearly a ton yeah
anyone tell you you can't do something
you're doing it yeah right so
growing up
i sort of looked at
my life my mum my dad and i wanted more
i wanted what all the other kids had i
wanted what everyone else had right
which days of my life well i've never
had what other people had so i was
become fixated on the sweeney and things
like that yeah yeah and then i started
looking at things thinking oh i want
some of that
and then
i put myself in the firing line to be
groomed yeah because i was that kid
that was an eager
eager to do anything for you to show you
that i'm that guy so
what you want i'm sure how many times
five times i'll do it don't even pay me
i'll show you what i'm going
oh you want to stab you want this you
want i'll do it well i'll show you and i
was always trying to please
other people to be accepted
when i got accepted
it was
i'm a
self-inflicted groomed individual
because i i wanted i wanted the
attention you wanted the accolades i
wanted the accolade i wanted to be on
the landings i wanted to be a cat i
wanted to be the baddest gang so i
wanted to be hard i wanted to have a gun
i wanted to get shot i wanted to become
i want to say how [ __ ] got better
what ain't no longer getting shot your
mug because that was my mindset
we had the other thing with the fish and
chip shop
my mum and dad all that boy just going
fishing chip shop now these are straight
people right
working from there from 11 o'clock in
the morning till 11 o'clock at night
covering fat i'll go and see these
people and he went
they've got my daughter on heroin and
they're trying to get her on the street
these two turkish guys i went well he
said they wanted to be a prostitute
and i went that ain't gonna happen
he went bobby we we working people he
said we wanted to go away i said i'll
make it go away don't worry about that
so i had invented this this thing where
i could put rock salt take the pellets
out of shotgun put rock salt in there
right
doing without stings it rips the skin to
pieces but there's no forensic because
it all melts with your blood right
that's my little trick but it's stinging
i used to call it the stinger and um
i said that one and he's having another
biscuit team marvin i've gone upstairs i
don't know biscuit now it's where he's
obviously fiddling the tax but that's
their little life savings he went
i don't want your money i said what you
do if my mum and dad come in here or any
of the boys for a fish and chips one
night you're giving me free i said i'll
do this i said it's gonna go away so
i'll see frank i went back to the pub
because in the end dates i didn't drink
a toy bit of lemon
and i went to the frank i said
that's terrible you know
he said i know but i went
get kennedy in the morning put rock salt
in one live one in the other he went
what's happening i said we're going to
work
so it comes around
there in their little lock-up that was
repairing cars right but they were
selling arrowing and all that
one's under the car so i walked in
boom done him in the fire went straight
in the office and stuck the radical
country's brothers out when you're
showing off this man in 24 hours now
blow your brains out you've got where
i'm coming from so they've gone in 24
hours allegedly i did this all right
allegedly
allegedly did these things right
and i always say allegedly because you
know i've done it right
i used to believe yeah yeah
without a shadow of a doubt yeah i'm
waking up in the morning
putting a gun down inside yeah
getting in my car putting me gunning me
hiding place putting me bits and pieces
back driving to pick other people up
with guns that's right grinding nick
money with guns yeah and going to take
drugs and believing at the end of the
day yeah looking in the mirror i'm
sensible yeah
i know i'm looking back with retrospect
now right looking back because i look
back on my life lunacy and i was yeah it
was absolutely lunacy we was off a
rocker son no two boys about it
we was a rocker because we thought it
was normal
like we talked a lot about different
things for our life what was your
highest point in crime in your life
oh
but the highest point
the highest point i got to in my life in
that
was i was going to get
financially i was going to get 88
million
and i felt
this was
the point this was my life this was it
this was
all over and this is what my life's been
all about
but that died very quickly
that died very quickly but that was that
that was the
highest moment of my criminal career
what was your highest
sort of what was your peak your peak
moment or spirit well as i said i didn't
like bullies and i don't like people who
abuse people
probably i did violence relieving i
didn't do bad manners right the honest
point i think has been the triads back
down
i thought now i mean you're talking
about naughty familiar i thought
i could do anything i can do anything i
want but really it was the worst point
because it gave me such an ego made me
believe i was
invincible and that's what got me put
away
i'm funny should say that
because that point
my dad had fallen
from that point of 14 with my dad
when i put a blade up to my dad's phone
and backed him up out of my ass time to
get out yeah yeah that point there i
thought i was invincible for the rest of
my life i've no longer touched me it's
i was psychologically prepared
for the sentence for the block
absolutely
no remission for the everything right so
i knew i won't get another mission i
knew i was never getting a d cap because
i didn't want it so i was going to go
prison i was going to be bad and i'm
getting out
on my edr so i've got no license that's
my mindset that's right yeah so i didn't
care about the rules and regulations in
prison and i won't care about the level
of time in prison because i didn't care
because i know i'm making money in
prison no matter what i'm doing anyway
what went through my is when i was in
prison
i thought that went well can you do this
i ain't doing nothing
i went on not playing your games
i said i'm not playing your games i said
you've played your cards i said what are
you going to do put me in jail you got
me down the block you know what can you
do i ain't played my card yet
and people took me very seriously i went
no no no you're playing your game i
ain't even started yeah and that's what
was the sit downs in prisons and
messed it up as much as i could and they
went to me about parole you told me i
went are you having a laugh i said
i've taken an assistant governor hostage
in a maximum security so everywhere i go
i've got loads of prison offices around
because they think i'm going to take
another one right and that's six or ten
man unlock 10 million there you go
what does that mean it means only only
10 officers in riot gear with a governor
an esso and a po can open your door
but as marvin was saying and i'll pick
up on what you're saying
if you're not prepared to if you want to
eat the meal you've got to pick up the
bill so you've got to prepare yourself
for prison so what you have to do is you
have to bring not only your body in the
prison but your head into prison so in
that actual life for x amount of years
and whatever comes of it because when
you're in maximum security i mean i've
seen people stabbed to death in there
i've seen people cut their resting their
self in there giza's getting boiling
ball up with salt are we sugar in it
straight over here burn their face off
it was killing each other one of my pals
got stabbed at their frucky eye over and
over yeah yeah straight through the ark
killed him over an onion
yeah what happened was with the onion
rocky had got the mints and all that you
know we used to
knick the gear out the kitchen
all the others that prison food if he
was connected you had good food and what
they've done they've nicked the mince
meat they've got all the bits and bobs
it's an onion salt but wait didn't i
would the other guy nick the onion
because they was doing bolognese that
night and up so rook has gone out and he
was a boxer rocky he could have a rare
and so he's got the onion the guy went
well that's my onion look he's gone
going on your bike he's pulled the blade
out butcher's bun like he was in the
kitchen done him right through the ark
killed him so he died over an onion
everyone says
about serving a sentence and you don't
serve a sentence in place like in
parker's what you do is survive
ascendance
because every day
that door opens that's why you said the
wedges in the door that door opens
people could run in and tell you why
you're in bed and while wedges right so
this is what i love when i went i went
to the cat ageless right
um
basically they they chip a bit of floor
out that's right then put a bolt in the
chip so when you try to push the door
open it can't open
right because if you ain't got that
because in the in the cage i was like
come on i think it's 7 45 they bust all
your doors open unlock unlock and then
they then they leave the landing so if
you're going to get done in the cat age
hour it's 7 30 in the morning you get
your doors open you're coming they do
you while you're kipping and then that's
it you're done yeah so everyone's got
these wedges and i didn't know nothing
about that
yeah
and i got educated but all that sort of
stuff because everyone in there was a
potential killer when you're in canada
if they ain't done it they're quite
willing to yeah it was most parkers was
the most polite place i ever went no one
pushed in cues because if you didn't say
good morning someone they get paranoid i
think they're plot you're putting up on
them they put up on you you had the ira
in there you know
reggie crow down one into your landing
like charlie next door to me and sanel
misery the guy who uh qadhafi's man who
shot the guy dead outside uh regents
park mosque with a death one from
gaddafi we all used to get on together
we all and sweetest thing is everyone
knew everyone's capabilities we all know
what we're capable of so there's none of
this you know swanking about you know
you're dealing with a real deal with
anyone you deal with
what was your lowest point
when my daughter died
damn
yeah can't get any lower than that can
you ever i've got a bottle of brandy
right
i drunk the whole bottle and come get
it was that emotional
and i wanted to go out and i wanted to
rip someone to pieces the anger in me
was dude
it was
you hear people say you know oh you know
when your baby i know how you feel
because no you don't it's so personal to
each individual even if you had a
daughter who died
i couldn't say i know you feel because
it's too personal it's like someone's
punching put a hole in your chest and
rip your heart out it's the only thing
that brought me to my knees that's when
i realized i wasn't invincible that i
was a human being i could feel pain like
other people because i've never felt it
before she died when she was born
yeah
done me i might have done me for a long
time outwards no and that's why if you
like
in a way that took away my brutality and
give me back my humanity
yeah so
it's always the traumas though yeah i
didn't want to hurt anyone anymore i'd
never wonder anyone again what was your
last point mark
right the lowest point i ever had
in that criminal fraternity
is when
my son told me he didn't love me yeah on
the phone i was on in parkhurst yeah
yeah
don't you
and i've run out i said ah let me speak
today so i don't want to speak to her
because i've been talking about i said i
want to speak to you and this is because
they said i was a hitman in the paper
yeah and i've killed loads of people and
stuff like that yet
my son i've got to get on the phone and
you don't want to speak to me so i've
said that mr put my phone down on the
speakers
i said get him on the phone put my phone
put him on the phone and i said what's
my son he said i don't love you no more
i don't like you you
you're scary and then put the phone down
and i went back to my cell and i cried
my eyes out for about two days right and
it was just a turning point but that was
my lowest point and i'll never forget
that
i realized it weren't worth it for me
and i wanted to give it all up and
do what i'm doing now i mean like is
there an action you regret the most
the only
see
yes
being a criminal
and as mad as it sounds yeah that's the
only regret i have
is being a criminal but
i just wish i had a better
infrastructure in family and growth when
i was a kid and i just wish i'd been
able to go to school college and
university
however i'm still proud of the person
i've become going through what i went
through and achieving what i have is
there a single thing you were
yeah yeah
i mean on one wrap up
so you know you do it all the time time
up gag them please come on time gag them
and you got that space they're always
chasing your day behind you
but and i always like my work to be
clean you know if i'm not going to shoot
you i know it's going to take a long
time but
this happened someone choked on their
own vomit that weren't supposed to
happen
and it was an innocent
and uh i live with that even today for
the rest of my life
that is one thing i i
i can't get out my nut there was one
incident
that
i got involved and i got involved it was
it
escalated into nine inch rings
but the one
incident that i was alleged to be
involved in a guy got shot six times
and he was like my best mate
growing up and then you know like divine
and conquer yeah
and
one of my biggest regrets
was
being involved in that situation
when i walked away from
crime you're walking away from all your
old pals what is it it's not even the
powers it's the infrastructure it's the
money it's the resources yeah that
you've one day you've got everything
you've got hundreds of thousands of
pounds in products millions of pounds in
networks you've got cash lying about
everywhere and you just gotta go see you
later yeah that and then start with
nothing that was the scary thing about
getting into a straight wheel because if
i wanted money before i just get a gun
and go and get it yeah right but going
in a straight world i had to budget
and i've been no good at budget you know
i wanted money i'll go and take it you
know
i had to re-learn a whole lot of life
skills and it was scary how old was you
when you had to learn all that when i
come out of jail i was in my 40s
so about 30 years
now and i had fixated in my head i'm
going to make a difference i'm going to
make it change and that's why i've
driven i was on television radios 24
it nearly cost me my marriage you know i
was there yeah and um
and i see changing happening and i've
now got push it a bit harder because you
know i can't leave the thing i've done
i've got to go right to the end of the
game
and i pushed it and it started off with
six quid in my garage me and my mate
mark so i had six quid in my garage then
it became a national charity and then i
applied the government then going blowed
up this guy's a bit lively
what you set up
right with your charity and the laws you
changed and the position you got
yourself into
absolutely inspired me
to be the man i am today without bobby
yeah
i couldn't get insured on a car i
couldn't get house insurance i wouldn't
get a job if i never see you
and mark
going to buckingham palace and getting
that night
being around these people i would never
believe i could go straight
you were the beacon it's not at night
it's an idea
it's the same to me it's the same you
think like
you're getting touched by a sword by the
queen no no no no i've never let anyone
go near me with a blade not even
she might go gotcha no no no no one's
coming in my throat
yeah let me tell you it was in you but
you didn't know it was in you i know
where your heart is right and you're
you're diamond man i love you with all
my heart well absolutely amazing to have
you on
there i'll be seeing you very soon
so you'd have to stalk them for a little
while know their whereabouts what
they're doing where they go who they
talk with you know and then you find a
place you've isolated them and you shoot
them in it's like anything where you're
shooting them cutting them once you've
done one half it doesn't make too many